yeah don't ask a doctor about this stuff
no no no no they wouldn't have a clue i
mean 99 of them don't even know how to
script a testosterone for therapy
um so let's do um epimoreland because
this is another one that i've used for
fat loss
as well uh talk about how this works and
why it works
so this is my favorite peptide so i've
been using this peptide since 2008
uh is this an on and off one or is this
one so
yeah so so that's a great question so
i think personally if there's one
peptide that you can use
year-round it would be this peptide and
and for this very specific reason um
it's the only peptide um that increases
the body's natural production of growth
hormone without
any concomitant side effects which come
from other
peptides that increase igf-1 which is
interstitial growth fluid
which is prolactin and cortisol now
everybody that watches your show know
what sport is absolute sleep
distress hormones um you know can cause
fat gain and insulin issues imbalances
uh prolactin is the stuff you know you
don't want as man you don't want to have
hypo acting because obviously it
increases that you can get man boobs and
you can get
you know an excretion and all that stuff
but anyway prolactin is a hormone that
you want to keep under control
and some peptides not the ones that we
recommend but some peptides like
especially in the old days when there
was like ghr p2 and 6 and all these
other things
they increased prolactin and cortisol
formation so ipomerellin is the only
peptide that does not disturb any of
those other hormonal balances or cycles
so when you use it it literally is just
helping your body's natural production
in the pancreas um of uh
growth hormone of natural growth hormone
release so you could probably get away
with using uh epimoreland for like
cycles of three months you know to four
months take four to six weeks off and
then go back on it
um ippa marilyn for women is magic
like if you have a wife or a girlfriend
or you know she wants to get leaner or
you want her to eat leaner or whatever
you want she wants to look better in a
bikini i mean nipple moreland works
better than anything
you can also combine ippa marilyn with
tessa
marelin now here's the thing limitless
doesn't sell tesla right now
he's working on getting is actually
a fda approved peptide for men who
suffer from hiv
it's actually called a grift egrifta
it's extremely expensive go figure right
sell it to guys who have aids but it has
special proprietary uh
formulation that when you inject it
right into the belly
for men it tears through
visceral body fat that is deposited from
guys that have that
uh condition through hiv i don't know as
much enough about hiv as i probably
should but
i guess guys get a lot of belly fat so
in normal guys when you use testimony it
literally
is like a hot knife through butter
through belly fat you know when i did
this photo shoot this
for this book guaranteed shredded or
whatever and i got absolutely diced
i was using tessa morellon for about
four to five weeks before i did that
photo shoot and that stuff just
absolutely shred you but again right now
it's very difficult to get there are
some peptide companies out there
like peptide sciences and there's one or
two other ones that sell it
um but again as i always say i don't
disclaim i'm not going to disparage
other peptide companies but if i don't
recommend them
i don't think that their products are
the best i'm not saying that they're not
good i'm sure they make a great product
but
you know i'm only going to recommend
products that i can test and i can look
at it i can understand like you're
getting what you're getting
because that's very important to
disclose that right like research
chemical companies have
no scrutiny there's no governing bodies
or you know any panels or anybody
looking at it so you know make sure that
if you're going to use a research
chemical company that you
you either test it or you make sure
you're working with somebody that
actually is looking at the products and
knowing
you know that somebody who trusts you
recommend because there are other you
know
peptide companies out there you know
john um jean vaughan at
camp con lobs or canned labs you know he
makes good products
but just be careful you know and be wary
when you buy peptides from research
chemical companies
you